[Music]
in our special series school matters
we're looking at how this pandemic is
affecting students all around the world
millions as you know have been forced to
switch to online classes which have
created you could say
a whole lot of new challenges now one
high school senior is hoping to make the
school year just a little bit easier
meg oliver introduces us to sophia jaffe
she's helping kids of all ages in a very
unique way
a smoothie that i made and i have my
mask
and my backpack and i am ready to go
seventeen-year-old sophia jaffe is back
to learning in person at her high school
in toronto
good morning she calls it a privilege to
be physically in class
all the desks are socially distant and
this is
what our notes look like on the board
sophia like millions of other students
had to turn her bedroom into a classroom
back in march when the coveted pandemic
began
how did that make you feel that social
isolation
it made me really upset actually because
this
part of high school where you get to
flourish it's really difficult to have
that
being taken away from you and then there
was the actual learning
when sophia went to seek out academic
help online she was surprised with what
she found
i remember thinking that you know the
school systems must have great lists of
recommended resources for online
learning
and i was wrong i was binge watching
netflix while doing school of course
and i did some research on netflix and i
saw that they personalized their
recommendations based on more than 75
000 categories
if we could take that level of
personalization and technology to online
learning
it could truly transform the world so
this summer sofia launched her own
website
elearn.fyi a collection of more than 300
online resources
it's one-stop shopping with links to
everything from coding and museum tours
to foreign languages
the free site has attracted visitors
from canada
the us and more than 100 other countries
i was so excited i sent it to all my
friends
and to the teachers and i even asked my
principal at the elementary school
to make sure like to send it to her her
staff because
it is useful karen dancy's 14 year old
son
liam recently started using the site for
help in math
i have a lot more questions it's hard to
understand things like through a
computer screen but with these websites
i can ask the questions
at any time i want really and i get and
i get the answers and i
succeed and i learn and understand
things well it's been a rocky time
you know nobody expected this
researchers found remote instruction
during this pandemic could put students
anywhere from three to 14
months behind in school robin lake is
the director of the university of
washington center on reinventing public
education
there's a lot out there it's just not
organized
and it's not available in a way to
parents and educators that helps them
separate
what's quality from what's not worth
their time
walking back to class
and that's exactly what sophia is trying
to change
she's helping put order to these chaotic
times
how does it feel knowing that you are
changing the landscape of online
learning
with all the uncertainty of online
learning
it's really difficult to digest and i
know that it
i can't be the only one feeling that way
a feeling turned into action
in a time of need for cbs this morning
meg oliver
new york we've got two customers with
liam and his mom i love liam sitting
there mom was just as excited
as everybody else when we were talking
about so what did she do exactly she
took
everything like one-stop shopping yeah
yeah
i know we're like you know please
translate well yeah
but you know it all began because she
was doing an online course
yeah while watching netflix which did
not escape the attention of parents and
teachers out there it's like that's
going on a lot yeah it is
yeah so you go to one site and then you
can get whatever you need yeah and
that's what i mean
there's a reason the mothers and are as
excited as the kids because
because this has been such a challenge
for parents yeah your wife's a teacher
yeah
and it's just it's really hard getting
everybody focused on the same page and
when kids fall behind
it's very hard to bring them back right
now so bravo sophia jeffy well done